Europe security is our security the
worst of all is to crash out of No Deal
there there would be a really serious
and immediate problem for British
nationals keen
outside the European Union you cannot
have the same rights and benefits that
inside the centuries these shores were
attacked by enemies and invaders from
Europe but small recently well at least
since the end of the Second World War
Britain security has depended on
cooperation with Europe but will brexit
change all that will it make these UK
less secure more vulnerable or in the
words of that famous brexit heir Boris
Johnson is that all balderdash
in the world of defense security and
intelligence Britain is in the top tier
the UK's nuclear deterrent secures it an
envied seat on the United Nations
Security Council it's special forces are
admired the world over and are in
ever-increasing demand they're all
navies two new aircraft carriers are
expensive but the most advanced of any
nation and will give the UK global reach
when they turn operational in a few
years and it's three intelligence
agencies mi6 mi5 and GCHQ have some of
the world's brightest officers and
analysts we've been the only country in
the world that has been a member of NATO
a member of the European Union and a
member of the five hours intelligence
alliance it's given Britain a uniquely
powerful and influential position in the
world we're now kicking away one of
those pillars by leaving the European
Union 70 years ago this year the
Washington treaty was signed and NATO
was formed the transatlantic alliance
remains the bedrock of European security
to this day I don't see the EU as being
really relevant to our core central
defence interests that is NATO that's
the strategic relationship with the
Americans it's grown-up a capacity to do
useful military work but that is not the
center of defending Britain when it
comes to intelligence mi5 mi6 and GCHQ
have helped disrupt terrorist attacks in
Europe in recent years and in no small
part that has been down to the UK's
close relationship with the United
States our access in particular to US
intelligence fees which we can feed
discreetly where appropriate and with
American compliance or with American
support into Europe to bolster their
counter jihadists and other campaigns I
think is something which the European
nations in particular prize to this end
we have learnt that the heads of
Britain's three intelligence agencies
have been touring European capitals
reassuring their allies that Britain
will remain fully engaged after brexit
everyday intelligence officers from that
building mi6 share information with
their European colleagues it's normally
done on a bilateral basis but there is
also something known as the European
counterterrorism group which Britain is
a key member of and will remain so after
brexit because of the twin threats from
Islamic extremism and from Russia data
sharing within Europe is going on at
unprecedented levels and this is the
area that will be affected by brexit
whatever form that takes although not a
member of Schengen the UK is a member of
the Schengen information system giving
it access to passport data held by
fellow EU police forces in 2017 alone
that system was checked by British
police
539 million times Britain is also a
signatory of the European Arrest Warrant
it allows you members to request the
arrest and detention of criminals in
other countries without extradition
talks between them most of this
information is covered by data privacy
and data sharing rules and they're set
by the European Union now when we've
been around the table we've been able to
argue our case and the the rules on data
sharing have been very much in line with
our national security interests
after brexit we won't be in that room
and the rules will be set by other
countries and we'll have no choice but
to accept those rules with that in mind
the Prime Minister travelled to the
Munich Security Conference last year
with a proposal
in a keynote speech to global Movers &
Shakers she called for a security treaty
with the EU I recognize there is no
existing security agreement between the
EU and a third country that captures the
full depth and breadth of our existing
relationship but there is precedent for
comprehensive strategic relationships
between the EU and third countries in
other fields such as trade and there is
no legal or operational reason why such
an agreement could not be reached in the
area of internal security but Sir
Richard Dearlove another former head of
mi6 has dramatically criticised Teresa
Mays current deal claiming that it puts
Britain's security in the control of the
EU the first duty of the state above
trade is the security of its citizens he
wrote in a letter the withdrawal
agreement abrogates this fundamental
contract it would place control of
aspects of our national security in
foreign hands Theresa May is called for
a security treaty relies on her getting
a deal through Parliament but even then
the UK security could still be affected
any form of brexit makes our security
more difficult to manage in the same way
that it it damages our economy the heart
of the brexit the greater the damage in
my own view is that the best outcome for
British national security is to stay in
the EU that gives us full access to all
this range of instruments the next best
is to have a negotiated arrangement as a
third country it won't be as good but
it's a lot better than nothing the worst
of all is to crash out with no deal
there there would be a really serious
and immediate problem for British
national security if in the past being
an island kept Britain safe not so
nowadays modern security is built on
cooperation alliance is the foundation
of a solid foreign policy it is if you
like about safety in numbers the cliff
edge is not a good place to be stood
Alistair bundle Sky News